キュアピース
[拍手]
皆さんドクオ
食べたいと思ったことがある人どれ位いらっしゃいますか
あっちらほらいらっしゃる
なんだか仲良くなれそうな気がします排毒という名前を聞いただけでちょっとドキドキ
しますね
この毒というもの好奇心でちょっと食べてみたいと思った方もいるかもしれません
私も時な口実は1回食べたことがあります
今回はそもそも毒って何なんでしょう
そういうことを通して私たち一人ひとりにとっての何が得なのか
何が薬なのかを考えてみたいと思います
毒は意外と身近なところにあります
水やお砂糖も致死量がありますし
タマネギも犬にとってお得です
ジャガイモもこんなに芽が出てしまってはソラニンという神経毒の成分がたっぷり
逆にトリカブトという猛毒の植物がありますけれど
こちら特別な加熱処理をすることによって漢方薬の材料にすることができます
またベラドンナというナス科の植物ですがこちらは昔々のヨーロッパの貴族たちは毒と
わかっていながら少量を使うことによって瞳孔を開き黒目を大きく見せて美人になろう
としていましたが魔法の薬ですね
こういうふうに毒と薬は表裏一体で使い方次第で薬が毒になったり毒が薬になったりし
ます
こういったん食べられるものや食べられないものの境界線を越えていくのは知恵であり
それを制御しているのは心と法律です
津波に
日本には7000種類以上の植物が生えています
この中の後から10%が薬用植物とされています
身近なところでは一応の葉っぱも実は記憶力がよくなるというメディカルハーブで
ドイツやフランスなどではとっても人気です
こういったそれぞれの植物たちには1000種類以上の成分が含まれています
そのうちの平均4個から5個はその植物のオリジナルの成分です
地球上には20万種類の植物の成分が存在していてそのうちの代替25%が実験などの
積み重ねによって解明されています
栄養価とか人への影響やそれから安全性なんかも一生懸命皆さんが研究されていて
身近な植物でよく私たちの役に立つものから順番に回目がされている時期です
でもまだまだ残りの75%は人間がまだまだ知らない成分であったり
そもそも人間がまだ出会っていない植物もたくさん地球上には存在しています
そういったまだ不確かな認知されていない成分ですらも私たち人類は文化や風刺の中に
取り入れてきました
こういった昔ながらの何百年何千年という時間の中で莫大な経験則で積み上げてきて
仮説音を足してきた暮らしの知恵は少し
現代の日本では縁遠いものになっていないかなという感覚がありますそれはなんだか
もったいないなぁと思って3年半
前から北海道から沖縄までいろんなおじいちゃんばあちゃんの話を聞いたりしながら
薬草リサーチの旅に出かけることにしました
そのきっかけとなったのがこちらのハスです
ハスはベトナムなんかではよくお茶になっている植物なんですが日本ではこんなに
たくさんハスの葉っぱが生えているのにお茶を作っているところが少なかったんですね
なんだかそれは不思議だなあと思って
まずハス農家さんに会いに行くことにしました
すると薬草に関しててインターネットで一生懸命調べても全然出てこなかったんですが
現地に入ったらもうすでに産業になっていたり
暮らしにちゃんと根付いていたり本になったりしていました
なかなかインターネットとか sns を得意とする世代の人たちにはまだまだ橋渡し
が出ていできていない分野なんです
こうやって園地に実際に行くことでなんだこんな素敵なものがこんなにたくさんあった
なんて d ような出会いがたくさんある冒険を続けていくうちにだんだん夢中になっ
て
日本人よめぐりようになりました
そうする中で薬草三業が一体どんな課題を抱えているのかということが少しずつ見えて
きました
まず一つ目は作る人も使う人も高齢化してしまっているということ
これを解決する鍵はいつもの健康食品産業などの
い既存の市場から新たに新しいマーケットを開発することで
超えていきやすくなると思っています
次にん海外産の安いものとはまた違う戦略を立てる必要があります
ですので新しい価値を付けるブランディングや
無理なく続けられるような数価格の設定を丁寧にする必要があります
そしてローカル部と都心部ではなんだか仕事をする適正な規模感であるとかスピード感
がちょっと違うなという感覚もありました
ここは丁寧にすり合わせていかないとお互いがちょっとしんどくなってしまいます
今は都心部でも企業はどんどん大きくするであるとか
それから売上音どんどんも射止めていくっていうことが正解ではなくなってきている
時期です
いったいどういう働き方が私たちにとって豊かなのか
そんなことをゆっくり話し合いながら進めていく必要があるなと感じています
またカキドオシや陶器などの植物も皆さんご存じないかもしれませんがそういった道の
ハーブがたくさん生えていてその使い方もあまり知られていません
そういったことを現在のライフスタイルに合うような形で提案したりどうやって栽培が
できるのかも手探りで探していく必要があります
また新たに販路を開拓するとなるとこの辺をすごく時間がかかってしまいます
さすがに農家さんだけでは大変です
そこで多面的な他分野との連携が解決のカギになってきます
栽培から販売それから研究されている内容もたくさんあるのでそういったな0時を共有
しながら切磋琢磨していくようなそんな牛度を作りたいなと思い
その1本目として薬草大学ドームというものを始めることにしました
シンポジウム形式のイベントです
今すでにも私たちの暮らし方やライフスタイルなどが変わってしまいました
そこに薬草産業も適用していく必要がある時期です
大事な本質はそのままで
作っているものや伝え方や作り方方など
変えていく必要があります
でもなかなか課題が多くて難しいことなので一人ではとてもできません
そこで仲間を作っていくというところからゆっくり始めることにしました
最後に私から皆さんに提案が一つあります
皆さんが生まれた街住んでいる街をもう一回見直してみませんか
実は昔の人たちが未来に生きる私たちのために残してくれている宝物がたくさん眠って
いるんです
いろんな街に行くようになって来今日の大阪に帰ってきたときに
あれ
なんか楠多くないかなぁ
と気づきました
その理由は
大阪の年を町にある薬の資料館に書かれていました
昔戦争で薬がなくて困った思いをした人たちがこんなもうよしそうにも絶対させたく
ないという気持ちから
小脳という薬効成分を含んでいるクスノキを
神社や公園などのパブリックスペース2000本以上も覚えてくれていたんです
こういったお話は実は日本各地にあって
こちらは米沢の
動きの生垣です家と家の間の垣根をウコギという植物を使って食べることができたり薬
にすることができるようにしていました
他にも長野県の上田市でも街路樹に夏目の木が植えられています
こういった植物のほかにも会津の合図納車や
米沢のかてものなど普段どうやって生きていけばいいかの知恵が集まった本や緊急時
災害時ねでもこういった植物を超えがこうすれば食べることができるよという風に記さ
れた知恵も江戸時代から残っています
こういった暮らしの知恵 a のアクセスは昔から野口餌をたくさん知っている人と
話すこと
博物館に行くかと本を読むことなどで得ることができます
なかなか自分が住んでいる街は見落としがちなのですが他の町に何体かいくことによっ
て比較してだんだん自分が生まれてきた町のことも見えてきます
先人たちは既に手を打ってくれています
私たちも未来ニットないして何か残したいですよね
一緒に挑戦していきましょう
命を大切にし合える社会へ
ありがとうございました
[拍手]